herzlich willkommen in sallys welt ich
bin starr murat also bitte nicht
erschrecken
ich bin auch nur heute da es ist ein
ganz besonderes video für mich das erste
mal vor der kamera zu stehen hinter der
kamera und ihr seht mich jetzt
wahrscheinlich zum ersten mal in voller
größe vor der kamera das heißt ihr seht
auch ziemlich groß 180 bin ich leicht
von mir als hocker 180 will nicht klein
und liegt zu sein ist auch nicht schlimm
schlimm ist ein fdp ist aber etwas
anderes
auf jeden fall das ist ein video wo mir
wirklich sehr sehr nahe geht deswegen
habe ich das erste mal vor die kamera
getraut ich wollte einfach eine kleine
geschichte erzählen was uns in letzter
zeit widerfahren ist den letzten zwei
wochen widerfahren ist
vorneweg eine kleine anekdote die ich
euch erzählen möchte da waren strand und
dann strand man sehr viele seesterne
angespülten seesterne sind neben gewesen
da waren kleine junge so alt wie meine
tochter fünf jahre alt und er ist immer
am strand entlang gelaufen hat die
tausende von sehe ich lerne immer
versucht immer ein reinzuwerfen dann kam
ein alter mann vorbei und sagt dann zu
dem kleinen jungen zu kleiner dummer
junge warum du wirst ähnlich schaffen
alle seesterne reinzuwerfen sind viel zu
viel
dann sagt der junge gut den alten mann
an und sagt im alten mann
ja ich werde vielleicht nicht alle
schaffen aber für jeden den ich einst
werfe für den einen bedeutet das alles
deswegen habe ich jetzt auch dieses
video gemacht mit der sie zusammen mit
unserem team zusammen und ich möchte
euch eine kleine geschichte erzählen die
uns betrifft also ist diese eine
richtige reichweite bis zu zehn
millionen mal werden die video von der
szene monat angeschaut und wir bekommen
wirklich sehr sehr viel nachrichten von
euch nachrichten auch negative nachricht
in diesem sinne dass das leute uns ihre
geschichten erzählen dass sie
zwangsverheiratet wurden daheim werden
sind schlagen oder leute die unglücklich
verheiratet sind und versuchen von der c
liga tipps und tricks zu bekommen
bei uns läuft es dann natürlich alles
toll
wir haben gesunde kinder uns geht es
auch gut und bekommen diese nach
fragen auch von vereinen von von
irgendwelchen heimen mit kindern oder
mit mit flüchtlinge versuchen möglich
alles zu beantworten alles zu machen wir
schaffen das nicht immer muss ich
ehrlich sagen mit tun hat das was wir
privat tun können
und jetzt ist ein ganz besonderes thema
was unser letzte woche erreicht hat als
man auf der messe war da ging es um
einen kleinen seestern dieser seestern
der heißt leider und das ist sehr schwer
für mich das video zu drehen sich ganz
sagen dass das für mich eine emotional
der wahnsinn ich hab selber kinder und
der ganze marktplatz kommen weil es ist
einfach besser ich kann es sich sogar
abgesagt
also bei uns gibt es auch einen zeh
ständen wir zurück ins wasser werfen
möchten und zwar gleich ganz kurz zur
geschichte wir waren ja vor zwei wochen
auf der messe in hamburg
und als wir dort waren habe ich bei
unternehmen facebook posting kam ein
kommentar von der fa
ich kenne die fahrt man kannte sie bis
dahin nicht es war zu mir geschrieben ob
ich nicht da ich leider eine video
botschaft schicken kann
am anfang hat es ganz harmlos aus weil
ich werde jeden tag gefragt auf
instagram auf facebook youtube sally
bitte schickt mir mal eine
videobotschaft meine schwester meine
tochter mein mann oder sonst wer wird
sich darüber freuen
aber bei ihr war direkt auch eine
internetseite mit angegeben und hat mir
geschrieben dass es die leute einfach
nicht gut geht wir haben zehn jahre
angeschaut und genau und dann hab ich zu
mir genau da habe ich einfach
beschlossen konstatiert wird es sowieso
auf der messe und da kommen die ich so
viele menschen besuchen dann habe ich
einfach auf der messe die kamera
ausgepackt habt dann auch kurz meinen
zuschauern erklärt dass ich jetzt ein
kurzes video machen möchte und der
moment auf der messe das war total krass
als ihr müsst euch forscher auf der
messe das sind tausende leute und ich
hab dann kurz von der leiter erzählt
habe gesagt dass sie zehn jahre alt ist
an leukämie erkrankt ist gerade im
krankenhaus ist und das ist er wirklich
nicht gut geht und im saal war einfach
von muxmäuschenstill macht wirklich
keinen mehr gehört und habe mich dann
mit der kamera umgedreht und für die
leiter mit meinen zuschauern eine video
botschaft aufgenommen was er einfach
etwas motivieren sollte und bestärken
sollte genau eine halbe stunde später
war es glaube genau und hat von der
leyen
im foto zurück das war der wahnsinn also
ihr habt ihr auch erfreut über die
hinaus jetzt so wie früher ausgesehen
wie das kind dann richtig da mal gelacht
hat den daumen nach oben gemacht hat das
hat uns so so berührt und das hat mich
halt oder unterhalt auch die kann also
ab dem zeitpunkt die ganze zeit
beschäftigt und zwar so dass wir
unabhängig voneinander die fahrt mal
angeschrieben haben und der murat dann
sogar schon mit ihr leid dass papa
telefoniert hat und seit dem zeitpunkt
ist jetzt etwa zwei wochen beschäftigt
uns deshalb ziemlich stark und leukämie
auch leukämie
was ist passiert wohl einfach wissen was
können wir tun weil wir weil die einfach
gemerkt haben wie sie leider hat man uns
erzählt die leider würde stunden lang
unsere videos anschauen des videos
anschauen und wir haben fast immer tun
sie den kontakt getreten sind dann nach
stuttgart runtergefahren haben also mit
dem papa und die gelaunt mal getroffen
und haben praktisch so die
krankheitsgeschichte das erste mal so
richtig vom papa erzählt bekommen und
das ist ziemlich hart also man muss sich
jetzt vorstellen ich habe auch zwei
kinder und bin echt gut froh dass beide
gesund sind bei der leider wasser also
als sie sechs jahre alt war das erste
mal leukämie diagnostiziert und schwerer
schlag für den verlagen die ganze
familie hat es auch erzählt als er bei
der arbeit brachte anrufe bekommen ein
kind hat leukämie
dann ist sofort ins krankenhaus gefahren
mit dem kind hatten seine ganze
leidensgeschichte sind direkt mit
intensiver chemotherapie angefangen so
schlimm war dass wir den job verloren
hat dann wurde es wurden also gespart
wenn also leukämie schon der tödliche
krankheit wir lassen jetzt nicht so
krebs blutkrebs und es gibt
heilungsmöglichkeiten es werden auch
einige was eigentlich sehr viele auch
geheilt und mit chemotherapie oder mit
stammzellen spende zum genau die
krankheit ist das schlimm
aber erstens auch das drumherum erklärt
mit der ganzen familie wie du dir sein
arbeitsplatz verloren hat wie er dann
wieder hoffnung gekriegt hat nach der
ersten bestrahlung wieder zurück zum
arbeitsplatz dann bekommt er zwei wochen
später wieder ein anruf das ist wieder
ausgebrochen
diese ganzen geschichten auch im
freundeskreis erzählt und mit was für
bürokratie mal zu kämpfen hat was man
alles tun kann sich ja nicht nur so dass
man sich dann mit seinem kranken kind
beschäftigt mit seiner ehefrau oder mit
einem anderen kind er die noch ein
anderes kind
es ist ja auch so beschäftigt sich
einerseits mit dem ganzen bürokratischen
kram denen du einfach machen musst dann
beschäftigst du dich mit deiner familie
dann beschäftigst du dich mit deinen
freunden die sich vielleicht alle von
den distanzieren weil sie also ich denke
viele haben einfach nur angst gehabt was
sie da machen sollen tun können und es
ist sehr sehr schwer
wir haben so was ihm bekannten sowas
nicht und als uns erzählt hat dass immer
alle da gesamt am tisch und haben dann
rotz und wasser gemeint also ich
furchtbar solche schicksale auch
mitzuerleben
also was uns bei der geschichte jetzt
einfach sehr berührt hat und wieso wir
da jetzt auch helfen möchten ist als sie
leider sechs jahre alt war haben eben
die krankheit und nachdem die
chemotherapie gemacht wurde hat man
gemerkt dass es eben nicht wirkt das
heißt die mit für die leider gab es noch
die möglichkeit mit der
stammzellenspende
und dann hat der papa gesagt komm mir
leider wie wärs wenn wir einfach ein
video aufruf machen und wir mobilisieren
alle menschen dazu dass sie einfach
losgehen und sich registrieren lassen
bei der dkms
das ist die deutsche knochenmark
spenderdatei da kann sich jeder
kostenlos registrieren
da bekommt man zum set so geschickt sind
zwei stäbchen drin machte den mund auf
steckst du die stäbchen rein schickst du
wieder ab und dann wirst du registriert
man muss natürlich auch dazu sagen das
ist auch immer mit kosten verbunden
das heißt vielleicht an der stelle finde
ich kann man sich schon was sagen jeder
sollte sich bei der dkms registrieren
lassen ich bin da auch schon seit jahren
registriert habe auch schon mal so ein
päckchen zugeschickt bekommen wo ich
jemandem hätte helfen können
es ging dann leider doch nicht alle die
nicht spenden können können zum beispiel
auch geldspenden weil das ganze ist ja
auch immer mit kosten verbunden das
heißt man muss ja das ganze dann
aufnehmen und so weiter da kann man sich
einfach mal informieren wir packen den
link auf jeden fall genau in dem
verborgen leider hat geholfen hat dieser
film mit mehreren hat sie gesagt also
wahnsinnige mit zehn jahren papa film
ich vielleicht kann ich auch anderen
menschen dabei helfen oder und andere
spender finden man in dieser spender die
dann gefunden also die sich registrieren
lassen können nicht nur für die leider
da sondern für alle menschen das
für alle menschen da eine riesen datei
genommen und jetzt gesagt ich mach das
video weil ich nicht nur mir helfen kann
sondern eben allen menschen und es ist
toll in der geschichte warten haben auch
viele promis geholfen haben auch mit
video aufrufen der fahrrad alles getan
also in seiner macht stehende wasser
gekämpft wie ein löwe
das erste weg sie an leute ran gekommen
wie cristiano ronaldo manuel neuer zum
beispiel und diese leute brauchen
aufgemacht im endeffekt wurden 25.000
spender gefunden
drittel 1 registriert genau registriert
und von diesen 25 haben dann 40
nachhinein papa sie leider ist papa
angerufen aber zu ich bekam einen anruf
ich durfte helfen also die leute haben
sich richtig gefreut dass sie hier
anderen menschen das leben retten können
40 spender wurden durch die leider
gefunden
dadurch dass sie sich die mühe gemacht
dass papa film ich einfach kommen macht
und zeit mein schicksal und 40 leuten
wurde dementsprechend auch geholfen dass
ich auch nachweislich das heißt sie kann
es sein dass sie 40 menschen das leben
gerettet hat dadurch dass nur das
traurige daran war dass diesen dass von
diesen 25.000 menschen die sich
registriert haben hier leider nicht
geholfen werden konnte da wurde damals
kein spender kein passender spender für
sie gefunden
was dann kam die chemotherapien und nach
dieser käme therapie ging es besser nach
ein paar monaten kamen die krankheit
wieder zurück das sind so rückschlägen
wurde immer wieder hast du kämpfst du
kämpfst du kämpfst kriegst du mal
rückschlage hat er ganz alternativ
therapien und chemotherapie ist auch für
den körper sehr belasten gefallen mir
die haare aus dies ist ein ganz einfach
verändern dann gar nicht schlechter kann
schnitt genau ich trinke nämlich auch
ein bisschen zu durch die ganze
medikamente und almen und jetzt war es
so dann kam dann wann war das ich habe
es gerade hier stehen dann kam der das
sind 15 2005 die krankheit zum zweiten
mal zurück genau und da wurde auch einen
fremdspender gefunden
zwar kann
ein junger mann wahnsinnig aus 21 aus
den usa der hat ein gespendetes coole
bei dem spenden war
du musst mit dem bestimmte milliliter
zahl musste spenden und der junge mann
hat gesagt gibt alles also zieht mir
alles raus was was maximum was geht und
wurde dann leider gespendet dann ging es
dir leider erst mal kurz besser
abtransport nach der transplantation gab
es in eine reha-klinik ganz kurz besser
und alles geht es wieder nur berg was
kam natürlich wieder kam es zurück das
heißt wieder ein schock für die familie
wieder alles sachen packen arbeitsplatz
weg arbeitslosigkeit münster umziehen
muss gegen inter klinik genau wie in der
klinik ist heißt das ganze leben spiels
leider das heißt jeder hat noch eine
größere schwester die größere schwester
kann auch nicht in die schule gehen weil
weil sie immer umziehen müssen vom von
klinik zu klinik von therapie zur
therapie und die ganze familie wohnt im
moment auch in der klinik weise in
seinem elternhaus direkt ich glaube 500
meter von der klinik entfernt
und jetzt ist sie leider wieder eine
therapie gehabt antikörpertherapie seit
november sein november und dann ging es
ihr wieder besser jetzt seit februar kam
sie kurz vor wer dieses video gemacht
der messe kam die krankheit jetzt noch
mal zurück den und jetzt erhalten
risikopatient und die antikörpertherapie
war in ist in deutschland einfach die
letzte therapie die es noch für ihr
leider gibt genau danach gibt es nichts
mehr
in deutschland und jetzt hat die familie
noch eine einzige möglichkeit das ist es
ist wahnsinnig traurig die einzige
möglichkeit die familie jetzt noch ein
bisschen usa
das ist die chance als therapie die wird
in deutschland noch nicht praktiziert
noch nicht das heißt es gibt einfach zu
wenige schon drüber und deswegen darf
man das nicht machen also natürlich
könnten die ärzte die therapie man auch
mal darfst hat einfach nicht weil es
einfach keine studien darüber geduld
müssen heißt auch sehr sehr hohem
aufwand also mir hinterher uns hat der
vater erzählt allein der flug nach nach
seattle
die die klinik es ist diesmal würde
kostet nur für die leider und für die
mutter 14.000 euro und das problem ist
ja mein fachliches geld dazu das heißt
also das problem ist dass diese
antikörper-therapie jetzt gerade
bekommen aber die schlägt hat leider
auch nicht an das heißt man hat jetzt im
prinzip alles schon versucht man hat
stammzellen transplantiert marge
chemotherapie gemacht man hat die
antikörper therapie gemacht und wenn
jetzt die leider in deutschland bleibt
und man kann hier einfach nichts mehr
für sie tun das heißt sie wird dann
innerhalb der nächsten wochen einfach
sterben was halt ziemlich dramatisch ich
meine man muss sich vorstellen diese
sechsjährige mädchen hat vor vier jahren
dieses video gemacht und hat vielleicht
40 menschen das leben gerettet und hat
alles dafür getan dass menschen sich
registrieren lassen und hat sich so
eingesetzt auch für viele und jetzt
gibt's halt für sie hier keine
möglichkeit mehr zu überleben das heißt
es gibt nur noch die eine möglichkeit
und das heißt sie müsste jetzt nach in
die usa reisen das vierte viertel da
gibt es eine klinik die eben diese
partie selbsttherapie durchführt und von
personen auch schon dort durch gefühle
nord ging es auch gleich medien von 30
kindern haben 27 überlebt ist es denn
ihre einzige chance die sie noch haben
und das schlimme ist dass ist am geld
hängt also das problem ist für mich das
schlimmste eigentlich das jetzt
kosovarischen leben diese dieses
zehnjährige menschenleben
das leben seiner tochter nur noch am
geld um geld entweder überhastet geld
und kannst deinen mädchen retten oder du
hast es nicht und deine tochter wird
sterben
genau und
ja es gibt auch schon ein spendenkonto
was der papa schon eingerichtet hat aber
es ist einfach noch viel zu wenig hier
müssen wir überlegen so eine solche
therapie die q400 500.000 euro und die
haben das geld einfach nicht es ist
einfach die letzten vier jahre haben
alle ihre reserven gezerrt und es geht
es noch darum die brauchen geld für
dieses spiel dass dieses michael lebt
und als vater wenn man eine tochter hat
und weiß denken nur ein paar euros also
sich am rand geld ist etwas furchtbares
vor allem jetzt stellen wir vorher hatte
tochter bei euch ist es so und und euch
fehlen einfach 200 300 400 tausend euro
das ist unmenschlich so was was würdet
ihr machen
als vater also ich persönlich würde die
nächste bank reinlaufen von bankraub
machen ja sicher alles tun um mein kind
bis zu ermöglichen diese letzte therapie
diese letzte chance so hat und wir haben
das thema machen
also haben wir uns im system uns über
die hohe ganz kurz was vielleicht
erzähle ich in der zwischenzeit kurz
ich wollte ihr leiter natürlich auch
persönlich kennenlernen und ihr größter
traum war es auch immer mal mit werten
mit mir was zu backen und das geht
momentan einfach nicht also ich habe
eigentlich schon alle bugs sachen
eingepackt wenn nicht alles organisiert
wir wollten uns eigentlich zu mir
hierher holen das geht aber leider nicht
weil es ihr gerade so schlecht geht
sie kann einfach nicht sitzen sie kann
auch nicht richtig aufstehen
es war einfach nicht möglich also wir
wollen echt ein krankenwagen mieten und
sie hierher fahren dass sie einfach mal
so in sallys küche kommen kann
vielleicht würde stunde mal abschalten
kann und ihre krankheit vergessen kann
aber das geht gar nicht weil das das hat
einfach alles überhandgenommen es heißt
es ist irgendwie keine krankheit
meistert er
es gibt einfach noch eine möglichkeit
dann sind wir zu ihr gefahren in die
klinik und ich hab sie besucht und war
wirklich schön also man sieht ihr auf
den ersten blick nicht an also sie stand
dann hat mich angelächelt und ich habe
mir echt gedacht also ich hab auch für
den kurzen moment ist einfach alles
ausgeblendet
habe ich mit ihr unterhalten und habe
einfach den papa auch die ganze zeit
beobachtet wie glücklich er war weil
seine tochter oft die mama die mama war
ja auch dabei wie die tochter einfach da
saß und drei stunden mit mir erzählt hat
er exakt aufgeblüht er sagt sz in den
letzten wochen nicht so viel geredet wie
sie in diesen drei stunden mit mir
geredet hat das hat er so viel mut
gegeben und so hat sich so motiviert und
dann habe ich soko leiter geschaffen das
wir schaffen das mit einer therapie in
den usa wir bekommen das geld irgendwie
zusammen und danach danach kommst du
mich mal besuchen und es wäre
wunderschön wenn wir jetzt ermöglichen
könnten zwar wirklich toll wenn wenn es
leicht ich meine zuschauer dazu
aktivieren könnte dass er alle mit macht
also es ist daran also wie hast du hast
über 10 millionen views im monat über
650.000 abonnenten
das heißt wir würden theoretisch wenn
jeder nur einen einzigen euro spendeten
nur einen einzigen euro würden hier
ungefähr so viel wie eine bretzel brezl
starbucks café 14 euro ein mac des
mikros 58 wir wollen nur eine brezel
verläuft das heißt wenn ihr uns diese
eine brezel euro das ist nicht für uns
ja heute leider zu schicken wird dass
wir diesen see stand alle zusammen wir
alleine schaffen es sich wenn wir diesen
seestadt allesamt ins wasser werfen
können und uns läuft die zeit weg mehr
wissen nicht ist noch zwei wochen ist
noch dreimal ist noch vier wochen
wenn wir das zusammen jetzt schaffen
würden das wäre der absolute wahnsinn
also ihr wisst für mich ist immer ich
kann immer noch viele sachen machen ich
lach mich jeden tag 15 mal tot aber dass
ich so was was wir jetzt hier durch
youtube erreichen wenn sich die sozialen
medien dieses diesen sicher ins wasser
zu werfen bitte lasst uns jetzt alle
zusammen einen euro zu spenden und zwar
gerade hier unten gerade hier in die
adresse einen euro zu spenden begeben
auch ganz einfach per paypal und ein
euro ihr könnt vielleicht auch mehr
spenden und wir also unser ganzes team
wir haben uns alle mit zu spenden
die jessica wir wir ach gott ist falsch
wir spenden dieser familie bei mir
diesen familienzusammenhalt einfach
gekannte schwinden
und weil es jetzt wirklich um was ganz
ganz großes geht wir stehen 10.000 euro
wir möchten 10.000 euro sich unser ding
wir werden auch weiterhin sammeln
wir wollen dass dieses mädchen diese
therapien bekommt und diese letzte
möglichkeit bekommt und zu übernehmen zu
überleben es ist wirklich also es geht
jetzt wirklich zu blöd anhört wir
konnten es wieder und ich anders machen
wir haben uns tage lang überlegt wie
drewes video ich habe das video gerade
78 mal schon gestartet
wenn ich dass uns einfach so nahe geht
bietet spendet uns bitte spendet uns da
oder spendet hier her da vielleicht noch
ganz kurz sagen leider
der papa hatte ihr leider gefragt leider
kaum spendenaufrufe sag doch sagt doch
in die kamera uns fehlt jetzt nur noch
an geld wir brauchen nur noch eine
geldspende und dann kann mir das leben
gerettet werden und die leiter die zehn
jahre alte wunder ich bewunderte ich
wirklich für deine stärke und auch für
deine weisheit hat gesagt sie macht es
nicht weil es jetzt nur noch um ihr
leben geht
sein papa ich möchte die menschen nicht
an betteln dass sie mir helfen
es geht nur um mein leben auch wenn die
menschen für mich spenden ich es kann
nur noch mehr geholfen werden und nicht
mehr anderen menschen und ich fand das
so bewundernswert dass sie einfach vor
vier jahren gesagt hat sie machten video
um auch anderen menschen zu retten um
auch andere menschen zu retten und jetzt
sagt sie macht nicht weil einfach nur
noch sie da steht genau also wir werden
weiterhin späten wir werden alle nicht
selbstlos
wir werden jede woche werden wir euch
zeigen wie viel spendengeld banken
angekommen sind
vielleicht schaut es um die große firma
oder jemand der vielleicht ein bisschen
mehr haben jetzt große firmen zu schauen
ich weiß dass uns auch große firmen zu
schauen kritisch irgend jemand dabei der
mich dabei unterstützen möchte da uns
unterstützen möchte und deshalb komme
ich spende ist eine riesensumme ihr
könnt dadurch ein menschenleben retten
genau wir würden dies auch öffentlich
machen willkommen und es drehen um und
auch zeigen weil es gibt den spruch im
türkischen hat es was die rechte hand
tut soll die linke hand nicht sehen
das heißt wenn etwas gutes tut sowas
auch nicht mehr zeigen und sagen und tun
aber sonst keine möglichkeit hat
noch einen ganz tollen spruch ich bin
zwar muslim aber ich kenne ihn aus der
bibel und zwar lautet der tue gutes und
rede davon zwei gutes und rede davon
dass heißt ihr habt jetzt die
möglichkeit uns zu helfen oder derlei
dazu helfen dass wir helfen können und
wir werden euch nichts also leider
belassen ich nicht im stich ich weiß
dass du dieses video anschauen sie haben
ich hab dir versprochen wir werden das
schaffen wir hatten wir lieben dich über
alles und der vater und die mutter ihr
seid wirklich wahnsinnige älter als
nachtisch schwester alena wahnsinnig
viel kraft und wir schaffen das alles
schon vielleicht sehen es auch um die
youtube momentan vielleicht habt nicht
dazu animieren die promis ihr habt alle
was zu sagen und ich weiß es gibt so
viel unheil auf der welt man kann nicht
alles zugabe lasst uns doch diesen
seestern jetzt mal rein werfen und dann
lass uns weitermachen also wir für den
seestern privat das zu machen was nur
geht und helfen uns einfach bitte helft
uns damit wir helfen können und dass wir
die leider ins wasser werfen könnt jetzt
in der infobox steht noch mal die seite
von der leider in den kommentaren wären
es posten ganz ganz wichtig ihr teilt
viele von euch teilen immer alles bei
youtube bei facebook so und ich bitte
euch echt nie darum vor der kamera meine
videos dateien kommentieren oder zu
bewerten
aber in dem video will ich euch recht
auf fordern deshalb das video was auch
toll ist wenn ihr noch fragen habt
irgendwelche fragen also vater von liza
der hat wirklich sehr sehr viel momentan
zu tun der kämpft graffin möge aber er
schaut es wie jetzt auch an und er tut
euch bin jetzt fragen habt tut euch
direkt die fragen beantworten unter dem
video so gut er ist kann das heißt bei
facebook youtube oder beantworten
schreibt eure kommentare darunter was
ganz ganz uns was uns ganz ganz wichtig
ist schreibt uns jetzt nicht runter habt
das möchte ich mir von euch nicht hören
was mir tolle menschen wir sind wie toll
die aktion für das möchte nicht viel
mehr von euch gar nicht hören tut uns
eingefallen die leider schaut das video
jetzt auch an schreib doch mal leider
wie toll das finden was sie getan hat
wie viele menschen sich schon geholfen
hat wünschte einfach viel viel kraft und
gottes segen
und wie gesagt schreibt es darunter wir
möchten nichts von hama schreibens nicht
drunter tolle aktion fehlen bitte
schreibt einfach
ein gruß an die leider es ist einzigen
echten es muss mit dem niveau und
schreiben es geht um die leider okay ich
hoffe beim nächsten video das ich das
ist dann wenn ihr station amid c das ist
vielleicht ein bisschen lustiger wird
oder ich habe genau also versprochen und
vielen vielen dank fürs zuschauen dass
er bis zum schluss noch ein geschaut hat
wenn es irgendwie übersät bitte bitte
helft uns
wir versuchen was wir können und
versuchen noch mehr spenden aufzubringen
uns läuft die zeit weg wir haben
wirklich nicht mehr viel zeit biete
spendet dankeschön